ah
I'm an American and I believe that
democracy is hard but worth it I'm an
American and I believe we can keep
advancing the causes and values that we
hold dear I'm American and this is also
my country too I'm an American and I
believe that we just want to be happy
I'm an American and I believe we thrive
on our diversity I'm an American and I
believe climate change is real and that
Americans can each do their part to
address it I'm an American and I believe
that your character isn't based on your
sexual preference or your skin color I'm
an American and I believe we can heal
I'm an American and I believe that
fighting for what's right is worth it
I'm an American and I believe that even
though we're all different we can learn
to accept each other I'm American and I
believe that giving up is not the answer
I'm an American and I believe our future
depends on the actions of our people I'm
an American and I believe people have
good in their hearts I'm an American and
I believe that we should build bridges
not walls I'm an American and I believe
we can overcome anything
[Music]
Wow
[Music]